I love this story let's call this the
bagel caper according to what I heard
out in the hall Ronnie has a special he
calls it his desk
it's a filing cabinet so Ronnie puts his
bagel on the filing cabinet all wrapped
up he walked away for a while he came
back and the bagel was opened up the
wrapping was off of it he blew a fit and
started screaming who touched his bagel
not only is he but there's two other
security guards all stands right by this
filing cabinet nobody knows who touched
Ronnie's bagel
but their security and nobody knows how
do you not know who touched your baby
what do you mean your security I went
out to the store other guys they went
out to the kitchen to get a drink go
ahead I went out there I made a bagel
wrapped it up nicely
what do you wrap it in a bunch of paper
towels okay wrapped it up real good yeah
put it down on top of the filing cabinet
which is your dad yeah my dad I tell the
story I come back bagels all unwrap the
paper brows are gone what is the bagel
sitting on there was one little napkin
sitting on top Ronnie no [ __ ] with your
food you [ __ ] oh I be livid I find it
incredible that three security guards
don't know who walked into the room were
you guys in there I was gone why don't
you ask you are the two buddies who what
who [ __ ] with your bed sure they know
who did it and I know who did it
go ahead only one person there so he
loves to [ __ ] with me because he thinks
everything is a big joke so who was it
Perlman Perlman he was on the air once
this is a guy that works first that was
shot was Mike [ __ ] with Ronnie's
bagel they're trying to [ __ ] with my
head they're trying to rile me up
everybody's after you yeah Mike what's
going on here
I agree with your hundred percent never
never [ __ ] with anybody's fool no and I
wouldn't do that raise your right hand
I'm gonna swear you in like Corey
Lewandowski did you [ __ ] with Ronnie's
bagel no I this morning were you at any
point thinking to [ __ ] with Ronnie's
bagel no did you walk into the room and
Ronnie's bagel was there all wrapped up
didn't see him wrap it up I'm wrapping
it up in okay so Ronnie's not crazy when
he said he wrapped up a bagel because I
was thinking maybe just forgot yeah all
right okay I'm into the witness you be
quiet
yeah all right you have children right
yes I swear on your children they do my
job and you weren't in on it you don't
what do you think had what I think
happen was this I think he what he does
is he puts a number of paper towels on
his bagel and I think he only put one on
because when he came back how many were
on there don't lie to me man no how many
papers were all there first of all there
was a napkin on top a napkin actual all
that was there and that's what you did
in the first mill [ __ ] I wasn't
buying took the paper towels which I
always do I took three or four my wrap
it up tight and that's how it was laughs
is it possible that the bagel wasn't as
tightly wrapped as you think we're gon
napkin was sitting on flat on top of it
which I didn't even put there you and
two security guards stand there and no
one knows who went in the room and cried
I went to get something to drink
you're right and when I came back this
was all done did you say to them I was
gone three minutes maybe so who could
have walked in three minutes at those
two guys didn't study have no idea ghost
it with me because you love to rile me
up always constantly Broyles you up yeah
he loves doing it you know where it is
it's you I know it's you by the way
what do you [ __ ] tell me any
different
no security what you [ __ ] to one of
your security guy buddies thinks that
you forgot how you wrap the night oh yes
what I think have no way I think you
know I got my [ __ ] way Howard I did
see him doing something with it with the
paper towels or napkins whatever it was
I took a number I think him up tight I
think what you [ __ ] on how good the
guy's not see who walk tonight
didn't wrap it that even your own
workers think I'm saying you might be
forgetful
yeah I'm forgetful forgot where I
[ __ ] did like a night do it every
[ __ ] Wednesday dude don't tell me
what Ronnie you were only gone three
minutes how could your baby what's the
joke if someone messes with you this is
a [ __ ] joke let me ask you where's
the rest of the paper towels that you
why don't you look around did you see
are they in the glamour spell I have no
idea I didn't - you investigate that's I
don't need no [ __ ] investigation I
don't need no Homeland Security this is
Ronald J I have a problem oh I know
somebody [ __ ] with it that's all I
know and that's all I care about
I know well I didn't cooperate well I
have a big problem you have a team of
security people in this building that
don't know if someone did in fact [ __ ]
with your bagel did you did you ask them
you're the [ __ ] head of security
stupid also they just think that
Ronnie's forgetting the way he wrapped
it right yeah I just laid a napkin on
topic that's called wrapping Gary I'm
starting to believe you forgot I'm not
trying to [ __ ] your head but you might
think you did [ __ ] believe that
forget the bagel where's my dildo oh
wait it's in my ass maybe I should
[ __ ] forget to wake up in the morning
come here it's a great idea up to you
wait I don't where am I who are you lady
behind the glaze the brawny puffs on one
of the symptoms of dementia yep
irrational mood swings [ __ ] with my head
and I will be irrational I have a
horrible feeling then I never wrapped it
I know know that you kind of wrapped you
know I know exactly what I did because I
went and got extra [ __ ] paper towels
and now they're all gone
all gone except for one
the garbage not a [ __ ] paper towel a
little [ __ ] napkin this bid you're
sitting on was sitting on top of it like
a cocktail now I wrapped it up again and
locked it in the [ __ ] drawer maybe
maybe you
that's a dementia thing - laughs don't
be food and drawers well you have
somebody with dementia somebody please
get Ronnie another bagel CSI or do you
want me to bring in a bagel sir Ronnie
could show us exactly how we wrapped it
by the way bring the paper towels also a
whole bunch of them [ __ ] plate I had
a big plate all right who cares just
show me how you wrap it come here Gary
don't don't listen to Ronnie he's losing
his mind Gary show me what you do
everything he's gonna demonstrate looks
like Kreskin doing a masters rat blew
away by itself
I'm telling you here's what about my
guesses right unless this guy Mike is
lying back would you say you did in the
first shut the [ __ ] up
I grew in mine I saw you doing something
with a napkin I did you were getting
ready for it
what were you doing [ __ ] me now Mike
what were you doing there for this
segment we got guests that are coming in
we're preparing are you doing getting
released Sonny he's busy watching your
stuff I was watching him right you
shoulda bagel I know exactly what he was
doing
I'm gonna make him [ __ ] with me Mike
because I know what you were doing I
have a guess I have a guess you're
running this morning cuz you're a lot of
stress now yeah you're really red yeah
I'm ready I am [ __ ] red man you look
like like a dog general I could be made
a fool out of Michael if anyone [ __ ]
with your bagel please come in I'm
giving you immunity
I'm giving immunity I mean
we pull the whole nobody over don't pull
you [ __ ] pool stick no pole president
he's taking polls back then and just
either your two other security guys both
do not believe that Mike had anything to
do so what do you think happened be
serious forgot because honestly I don't
think we did I think he put a napkin
down with the intent of wrapping it that
was in his head he turned around [ __ ]
yourself Sal is there cameras from the
place where you took the bagel into the
room can we see you take the bagel in
the room and then can we see somebody
else walk in the room will you will
agree that your cognitive functioning is
off if in fact we see no one walking
down at all no there were people but
he's asking you would you agree if the
tape shows nobody going in there but
they were in there already fool security
guy was in there so you're saying the
security guard stood there while Mike
screwed with your food I don't know if
he saw what Mike did I would never met
anyways but it's not something that I
would want done to me so I wouldn't do
it anybody else right I believe you
maybe like to bite a man Collin through
the window I don't nobody saw him Robin
what's going on here you're the voice of
mutiny think that everyone's against him
which is a paranoia that somebody did
immediately think that someone would
[ __ ] with your food because somebody
unwrapped my [ __ ] bagel it is
possible give me this that you forgot to
wrap your milk absolutely not hmm you
say there's no way we're on a thousand
Bibles yeah [ __ ] you okay all right I
don't remember and the worse news is
Jason just ate all the evidence listen
he's not eating my evidence because it's
locked up Mike you swear you're not in
on bagel gate I wouldn't want to see
Ronnie's gonna get [ __ ] away I don't
know that's not good fun I know I don't
see the joke I'm worried he's the
[ __ ] joke right here what that you
got
[ __ ] riled up like a maniac I don't
want you riled up yeah okay
you guys you know you now you are nuts
yeah I don't do this
I didn't say you to saying I want you
riled up no they want me riled up all
right Ronnie listen I'm gonna look into
this for you yeah okay I will do a full
investigation there's now an internal
investigation
the bagel dusted for fingerprints Robin
I'm putting you in charge of this
investigation you just said you were in
charge well I'm delegating